this is limited media
[Music]
what's happening this is hannibal burst
i'm here with kelvin stovall what's
going on kev
hey what's going on man this is uncle
kelvin how's
it unclear down man i mean you're you're
kelvin
i'm uncle kelvin no
because i'm an uncle too you but you're
not
considered uncle hannibal you're happy
to some folks
to a few just a couple people maybe like
two i think maybe three four
maybe four but you can't just i mean you
said so you're saying
in this con you're not the listeners
i get what you're saying but you're i
think you should try to
i mean if this is a new venture
and you're you're trying to to brand
i mean i guess that is your your
instagram is uncle kelvin isn't it
that's right i i spoke with money love
the rapper
yeah days ago and she referred to me
as uncle kell and i'm not her uncle
but okay love is and she referred to me
as
uncle kelvin there's a lot of people
that refer to me as
uncle calvin and there's you know look
but go ahead go ahead no you so
money love you you reached out to her on
instagram are y'all mad at the party i i
had met her
years ago at a a concert with big daddy
kane
um special
special ed it was special ed big daddy
kane grand master flashlight
she was there and she didn't call me
uncle kelvin then
because i wasn't known as uncle kevin
but recently she
made a post and i commented on it on a
live
and she was like uncle calvin can you
repeat this and she had the british
accent
uncle california can you repeat this
please
and so okay
well this this podcast might be uh it
might be a bad idea because it's gonna
go to your head then
i hope not uh i mean i don't
okay uncle uncle cal um
what do you call me
kelvin
[Laughter]
and i say unk sometimes right you call
me
uh sometimes most people call me
i'm at that age now like this uncle
snoop is being called uncle snoop
we don't really know snoop's nephews
well he do call a lot of people nephew
though
right so his approach is
his same title but he got there in a
different way i think he started calling
people nephews so much
that they just reflexively started
calling him uncle
and it was a it was a psychological judo
so we don't know if it's true i don't
know put like this
it's known that i'm an uncle well
uh i'm gonna do some quick research i'm
on my own my computer real quick
and i want to just look up when did
snoop
start getting called uh
as i said when it's new start uncle uh
when it's the first result like google
when did snoop dogg become snoop lion
that's the top result and it's like
that's not
oh snoop dogg is uncle snoop now that's
2014
that's been his but for aspiring rappers
that's been his name for a while
oh i guess you know as he became a
mentor and an elder statesman in the
game he started uh
he started just giving the fight being
you know
uncle well um uh uh i'm killed
uk uk
okay uk that's okay like
you can have that be a rap bar uk
i'm uk like a colonizer
[Laughter]
i'm uk like a colonizer
i got two shades like a blue blocker
that on brown
hey yeah man so
let's tell this is the first episode
first first who knows maybe it's a
limited series maybe it's 10 maybe it's
20 who knows
but we'll talk about what the the
concept is
uh you
you worked well for years
i worked in the casino industry
for over 20 years 20
years in the casino industry what what
years
did this does this span and and what
areas and casinos wow this
goes from i want to say
90 90
early 90s like 90 39 this is the first
real legitimate
legitimate job that i had in
legitimate society yeah you know
because i i did other things like
selling books door-to-door
crazy stuff like that and what was the
first casino job
first casino job i held was as a
i was in security i started out
i used to carry funds which casino
that was harrah's casino there's casino
hammond indiana joliet illinois juliet
illinois
yeah you remember your first day there
yes i do remember my very first day
i remember my very first day all right
walk us through it okay here we go
i needed a job because my mother said
that she was gonna kick me
she said i had to get a job
so my brother at the time worked at the
casino and he said
hey i'm gonna get you a job
so you don't get kicked out because mom
wants to kick you out i said okay fine
so he he's like i'm gonna get you
something easy
because i know you're not gonna work
hard and which brother is this
this is my brother vincent vincent
vincent edward he was named after
he told me he's like i'm gonna get your
job at security
they don't carry anything heavier than
20 pounds
easy job i'm like okay fine so he gets
me the job
i get the job and i'm doing that for
about
i want to say eight months
at the age of 21
and it became an opportunity for dealers
school
where people can learn how to deal cards
and
deal games to players
and i my brother suggested hey man you
should take this they make
good money it's easy work just standing
there
and dealing games he didn't tell me the
intricacies of
everything else but he was like man it's
easy i was like okay
go ahead take the class
because i didn't want to because i'm
looking like man it's like it looks like
it's a lot of
counting but it's really not it's like
patterns this is like
pattern it's not like a lot of counting
like people think
yeah took that job
got it and i started dealing i started
dealing at the
hares and he was
the surveillance manager and things were
going
pretty good pretty good you know
what what was the most
what was the time when you just realized
that this gig
oh this is different i'm around these
gamblers are
a different their their brains move
differently than mine when was the
moment where you like oh these are
this is a wild place
it would have had to have been probably
like
like a month a month in
and at the time this this is how crazy
it was they used to put
people off of the casino and they first
of all they had to pay to get on
to lose money you would have to pay the
casino money
to come in to lose money and then they
would kick you off
pay to get them on meaning they had to a
cover charge
it was a cover charge what whoa
when this when they first started it was
a cover charge to get
on the casino i think it was like 27
bucks it wasn't what wow
that's crazy was it free drinks though
no no there's never been free drinks in
the state of dylan
they have never been wow that's bonkers
i didn't i i didn't know that casinos
used to have cover charge
27 cup of charge and that only includes
going into the casino no snacks
no shows no zest the uh
for the right to gamble your money a
two-hour cruise they would take you out
um
like a half a mile away from the dock
and turn around and come back
two hours if you wanted to come back on
you have to pay another
27
it was crazy they were making money
and offense people used to hide in the
back now this is what made me like you
said
think like hey these gamblers are
different they would hide in the
bathroom
so they wouldn't get put off
so they can just keep gambling
high in the bathrooms hide upstairs on
the balcony it was crazy
damn that's insane
cover charge gambler so
the reason i wanted to start this show
is because you you just over the years
told me
so many different stories
about people gambling people walling out
people losing incredible amounts of
money people being
on tilt on tilt meaning
when people lose their minds through
because of the energy from getting they
lost a lot of money so they keep
gambling more and they're not really
being reasonable that's what on tilt me
so that's probably a term you'll hear us
use a lot on this show uh
and so man it's uh it's
really fascinating where what's what's
another one
so you you how long did you stay at this
harrison joliet
oh at that one i stayed there for about
i want to say four
five years then i was forced to resign
okay they forced me to resign
because apparently there was a conflict
of interest
because my brother was a surveillance
manager
and i was a dealer not considering the
fact
not considering the fact that i was
security at first
and was walking around with actual
dollars so it took them three years to
realize that
this was my brother even though he put
me down and i put him down as
a reference so they
they forced me to resign
after like three years three four years
three years
decent it was a decent run it was i had
no problems
and so did but then you just went to
another you went to another casino right
after that
i went directly to another casino they
offered me another casino when they gave
me my service package they were like
well we can put you at
another casino you know
you become what is known in the industry
as
a casino gypsy okay
when you go from casino to casino you'll
go from chicago
to lg to gary
to new buffalo to you
just travels like becomes a
like a traveling like a traveling job
and so you you would end up
uh each time moving
close to that to the casino in that city
see here's the thing i tried not to do
that after the first one
after the first casino when i'm left and
went to
another casino and i'm like ah i just
got
told that i can't be there anymore i'm
not going to go to state station
but a lot of people do that a lot of
them
but i decided not to so i just maintain
mid area mid midwest and i would just
attack
everything in the midwest area
oh all right what's
what game did you start off dealing
i started off dealing blackjack
i was taught by two women from atlantic
city
two girls from atlantic city taught a
class of about
okay start out black what's the most
money you've seen somebody lose in an
hour at the blackjack table in front of
your face
in an hour
about 350 000. 350
000 in
an hour
wow is this somebody we know
i'm not going no you guys it was it was
a banker type of dude i've seen
um okay he's a banker type let's talk
about more of these faceless folks
we don't want to become we don't want to
become that type of uh
podcast you know name
or not but we'll just talk about stuff
that happened
we don't get it but a banker lost 350
000. it was in less than
less than 15 minutes he had got another
350
000 after that when you're at a certain
point you
you get credit with the casino so oh
that's crazy so what so he was betting
what
maybe 25 50 a hand
yeah yeah
and was it a certain point where you're
like this is gonna be bad
this is this is you could see that it
was going poorly for him but it was just
the avalanche when
you just describe being at that table
well sometimes as a as a dealer you know
like okay i've been hot the whole night
nobody has won
on this table maybe it's just this table
yeah what people just lose and this guy
decided to have a private table
at the table i was at and i knew
he was not going to have a good good
time at that table
[Music]
i think he won one hand out of like
like i said he won one hand maybe out of
like 700 000
maybe one hand he would lose and he
wasn't playing horribly
he was playing basic strategy but
sometimes
the cards are against you yeah the car
that's the thing is just especially with
blackjack it's so
fast where it can just the pace of it
especially head to head sometimes like
yeah
head to head blackjack is only i mean i
don't
most gambling is only great if you're
winning but
head to head like if you're losing
it could just be so he's like god damn
what happened
where there's a little more you know
when there's a few more people at the
table just
it's a more casual pace
and it almost i know sometimes i be
feeling like
if the dealer dealing too fast i feel
like that's an attack on me
but i know that they tell y'all to deal
fast right
they push dealers in they deal the
fastest amount of hands right
that's a given they're not going to have
a guy that's back then
that's why they used to get mad at me
when they decided
to finally make me a highland i became
what is known as a
high limit dealer oh
i was one of those so the high limit
dealers
what's the criteria for becoming a high
limit dealer
there you go there you go it's hands per
hour
okay so you have to deal a certain
amount of hands per hour
and minimum mistakes
with pretty good customer service not
excellent customer service but you
like you couldn't be uh a [ __ ] if
they didn't tip
[Music]
um you just have to take it like
hmm okay you won 80 thousand dollars
good luck to you sir
well i think
does the does the casino tip y'all out
of big losses
no they no they do not so
yeah man i i i took well you know
during my gambling days if i if i hit
them i would tip just because
you should just this is karmic but i
don't think it should be
i don't i think if the house is
[ __ ] breaking [ __ ] in then they
should break y'all off
too cause that's that's who y'all be
around
more anyways you know what i mean those
are your folks
[Laughter]
those are your folks i'm just the
customer
with the house tip when that banker you
know lost that 350k
did they just like here you go here's
did they even throw a couple hundred off
of that
no you're gonna put it on on a lucky
[ __ ] that's like
just not even you know you don't even
know how they
mentally are handling a win or a loss
like no matter what they show you
some people show anger or whatever but
the tipping process thing that
might be a new who knows the casino
themselves they're always at the casino
so they know they're supposed to tip
they just don't
yeah yeah put like this
i ah man it's
oh and i bet you
here's what i bet you if there was
policy and signage
that said when you lose
we tipped our dealers
more people would tip when they went i
bet i
bet that i'm gonna po i'm gonna
i am gonna go ahead and pose that
question to a bunch of dealers that i
know
now what was the question again you said
if
the casino wins
they're gonna tip the
dealers i'm saying psychologically
if the casino had a policy
that said we hey when you lose but they
don't even want to
create the idea of losing that's that
that kind of that ruins the illusion so
that can't even be
the if you know what i mean because so
that this is this is a this is a
false uh hypothetical because a casino
would never be like
hey if you [ __ ] up it's just like you
know
that's not not a possibility today pour
the chips away everything's a dream
and so the money get taken so but
i think people would would you know
because i think that's part of it
right that's part of the reason why
people wouldn't tip
at a casino
is because they know [ __ ]
losing money
so they saying y'all and y'all ain't
getting a piece of that [ __ ]
and that and that and that becomes the
that becomes the debate how about give
you i'm gonna give you an example
here's an example i was working at the
casino there was a young man
and he was he had a very smart mouth he
was a very
flippant type of guy but he was honest
he was a very honest guy and
we were dealing roulette and
an individual asked him he was like how
much do you make an hour
and he said honestly honestly he said
the casino pays me eight dollars and
fifty cent an hour
that's because that's what the casino
was paying them eight dollars and fifty
cents an hour
you are not allowed to tell what
it includes with tips but you're allowed
to tell your
base salary which is garbage the base
salad was garbage
and he said 8.50 an hour and the player
looked at him and said this is
the god's honest truth i was there the
player looked at him and said
if you're going to be an [ __ ] i'm not
giving you [ __ ]
[Laughter]
it's on a guy without busting a smile
because i'm looking like he's not lying
and he's been like uh
like a robot the whole time he was like
one of those robot dealers
but he was like here's your bet here's
your payout just he was a robot
and when the guy said well i'm not gonna
give you [ __ ]
he said well okay there i make eight
million dollars a day
he was like what do you want from me
[Laughter]
it's like what do you want so
there's no weird situation
i witnessed that i'm like the guy didn't
lie
and the lady it was a was it a lady or a
guy i'm trying to think
because women sometimes can be so cruel
but i'm trying to think i think it was a
guy this time and he was like
if you want to be an [ __ ] about
giving you anything
you see yourself it's against the dealer
you feel a one-on-one against the dealer
you don't get mad
yeah you might if you're playing craps
you might get mad at the shooter if you
keep betting that don't he keeps it
okay like this guy is lucky
he's not i should be with him
yeah craps is funny like that because
you can start
it can get adversarial with the
other folks when you everybody's still
playing against the house
but you start because it's so personal
and it is kind of uh there's a flow to
it there's
technique that people have there's
rhythm
there's style there's flare
there's swag so
when people get on the dice and somebody
you know you could tell you know people
that think they shoot it you know what
i'm saying
and sometimes they write let's see if
some people think they shoot us there's
i've been in some zones i think i'm a
shooter i come up to the table i think
i'm here it's time i've been at the
table actually made a comeback
uh not a comeback but
when i was in canada that was actually
my last
my second to last gig before lockdown
was uh about an hour something from
toronto at a casino
and uh they had craps and i hadn't
gambled since uh
early 20 i think i stopped gaining
beginner 2019
and so i was like you know what uh let
me you know play
let me buy in for 100 200
and uh and then i got busy on them man i
went up about 12 1300 dog
it felt good it was like hey and i i
can't front when you
when you hot on the dice and
you got a girl with you the [ __ ] just
feel
fly man because you just you just
feel like some like type of magician or
some [ __ ] some
some oracle and you start calling you i
call my numbers sometimes
i mean like six dice six winners like
yeah
look at her and [ __ ] you know you get it
yeah
[Laughter]
oh it's like having like a killer
like hey everything i'm doing is working
right now
yeah you can counter
that off and on dice is the game
put like this but it's like controlled
anarchy
yeah yeah and this little in this little
world in this zone
these are the rules can you do it can
you roll these
numbers and what
what are your uh
what are your thoughts on dice setting
now for the listeners dice setting
is at the craps table some people
like to set the dice a certain way
before they roll them because they think
that will help them get their number but
so
say somebody's trying to get a eight
some people might like to
roll the dice with the four on top and a
two
and then a five and a three facing they
had these different so they like to
throw the dice from that position
and then some people just shake the dice
and just throw them no
setting or anything and some people have
a certain consistent motion
what's your thoughts on setting and
and throwing and technique i'm glad you
brought that up
i'm very glad you brought that up uh
last week i was at a buddy of mine's
house
and his his his his girl
used to be a casino dealer for about 12
13 years
and she was sitting box boxes the
position on the dice table that sits
down
and their job is to wash the dice
and she had individuals who were sliding
the dice
that's what you're calling it it's when
you set the dice
and you slide them so that they have
very little
role to it so wait
sliding though is a little bit
sliding the dice is slightly different
from what i'm talking about
it's it's the same principle
if you're not that's why people set them
because they think
when they draw them it's gonna land on a
certain number
that's why people hit the dice people
set the dice because they think when
they draw them
it's going to land with a certain number
now if you're a slider
and you're good with sliding the dice
one dice will remain the same or both
dices will like flip to the same number
and there's a young lady who she was
involved with that and she let them
slide the dice on her
for a good hour
[Laughter]
and then she wondered why she got flight
[Laughter]
she was like i i don't i saw him sliding
and i let somebody know and then nobody
tell nobody else so yes
if people are doing that like i say a
person throwing them
way up in the air and like
movie type of things normally people go
ahead and they let it go like okay keep
the
dice at head level uh lower
you know there's no need to do that
drawing them up in the air like as a
movie
but as far as sitting the dice i have no
problem with them if the dice
uh if they rotate
they have to have to rotate in the air
i'm looking at an article now that says
couple accused of
dice sliding at the win in
vegas uh this is 2011.
uh the strip resort has filed a lawsuit
against frequent customers
uh leonardo and veronica asking for the
return of about
seven hundred thousand dollars
[Laughter]
listen listen listen i i
there was a a team there was a team
in east chicago indiana
that was going to every casino and it
was sliding the dice
and they got a few people
they they got a few crews where they was
i don't know how much they picked up but
they was picking up you know i mean
pretty good money this
so that's when you say dice setting
that's what it's called
when they set the dice that's why you'll
see the stick person
will move the dice off the off the
number
yeah you know what i mean
yeah i don't like when they do that
especially if you know what i'm rolling
and if you if i if you know i'm rolling
up for a [ __ ] six
and you put the dice up with the two one
up all right what what are you what is
your motive what is your motivation like
do you you can see what i'm working for
you gonna put the [ __ ] on a
nine
you see what i'm shooting that's rude
because they want the dice to flip
they want them to flip they know if they
put on that number you're not gonna
roll it back to that number yeah
well so yeah
it's it is real and i talked about this
in my
in uh comedy comisato
about
battling people a little bit i didn't
get much into it but just rolling dice
and then
but then um rooting against people
um and
yeah just seeing somebody and just kind
of betting against them on site with no
other information besides just have
you have you been against somebody just
uh at the crafts table just based on
their outfit or how they look or how
they carry themselves
yes of course i've done that plenty of
times i don't
it's it's
if you look like you're gonna lose like
hey i've been
i've been losing all day yeah i
haven't been winning you're the past
live
i don't think you're gonna win now right
i'm going don't pass on you
not because anything personal you just
said you haven't won
all day
when people come
like like people always think there's a
they had a movie about it i can't
remember the name of the movie
um it's like
jinxes that they pay people to come to
the
no and i've seen people that were like
super bad luck like this guy has not won
he will lose i've been there so i can't
see it just people i've lost on
20 i've you know made one point than
seven out for the next three three
four so i i know i had goals
you know but i know if luck is not with
you
they're not with you it's all up so i've
definitely
been against people because like okay
this guy has been losing the whole night
whatever table he goes through better if
he goes to baccarat he bets on player
bet on banker so you stalk
people yes i have
i'll watch you play a slot machine
knowing that you won't hit
then i'll go to it after you leave
how much is that that uh
strategy work
i'm gonna be honest it's about a good 70
30.
it's about a good 70 30. i've seen
people that's been
losing and they just keep losing the
whole night
you know then i've seen people that's
like this guy has
the midas touch he's he is
winning the whole he can pick numbers
and cars and machines and whatever
yeah i've seen people there like uh
you could tell them head versus tails
and it lands up tails he'll bed tails
and the card
of the coin will flip at the last minute
to say hey
this guy's a loser you know
he gets blackjack the deal against
blackjack this guy's a loser
you know so um
but i've done that i've i've better to
get to play
people lose people have losing streaks
you do hey i'ma drop this beat real
quick because i'm just trying out this
software hold up
i think i might be able to
[Music]
hey
damn it did it fade out too oh [ __ ] this
is wavy
that's all getting ready to bust the
bars
oh you bought the bus bars
[Music]
is
float
yeah talk about casey that's why
i got different flows man that was the
slow flow
with the you know i mean i'm in this
i'm in a studio so it gives me that
what you call that that um this
this is the this is the justin hour
you know type of fear uh
i think this is a solid introductory
episode
once we trim it up uh
we gotta think of a name though we have
to we
we need to think of a name for this
podcast
uh i suggest it hit me
but then hit me is kind of bland if you
don't
hit me 21 hit nope that's not it uh
what was you what's your suggestion uh
casino chronicles
or i was thinking this hard 16
hard 16 r16
uh like uh
oh i just thought of one
what is it split intense
split tears it because i was thinking
double down or blackjack
double down on blackjack because we
gotta think split
or double down cause i've double down on
blackjack before
out of aggravation just because you were
down already
i was down [ __ ] already this was my
last bit and then the dealer tried to be
real condescending like
there you go you have blackjack you
might come back
i'm like yeah i'm down 300.
this isn't ten bucks
double down she was like what i'm like
i'm double you can't double down i'm
like
yes i can i can double down on any two
cards
call your manager call your supervisor i
hate to do this to you
and she was like are you serious i'm
like this
yes i'm [ __ ] serious and she was like
you don't have the ten dollars in
freddie
he goes my buddy had to do
i said give me two dollars man and he
was
like why [ __ ] you already got
blackjack
i said nope from doubling down on this
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] did you do about that [ __ ]
it they took my money
[ __ ] it let them take it all i don't
want to leave with [ __ ]
and he was like i was with me
and i was like just give me the tip i'm
gonna give the ten dollars back it was
only ten dollars
so i doubled down she was like she
called us
down on black dragon
blackjack
blackjack i'm the 23 year old [ __ ]
that works at casino up the street
they're doubling down
on blackjack yes i am and she
hit it and it was a 10 i'm like that's
21.
and they were like you don't get the
money and a half though i'm like [ __ ]
the [ __ ] up
these cards and i proceeded to play
every hand
but to make a long story short and we'll
continue this story later
i ended up winning that 300 back that
night hey out for that bad play
hey sometimes you gotta you know shake
it up you gotta shake it up to make it
back
got to man you gotta shake it up to make
a vac
you know oh whoa what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
[Music]
all right you know still still figuring
it out
oh man oh no
okay okay all right yeah
yeah man splitting tens
splitting tens that sounds good
splitting tens
splitting tens is that that's the that's
that's uh
that's that's that's it that's it i
think we got one
another one i mean another one
word man all right that's the episode
like you know one number one in the
books
episode one down yes sir
yes sir all right later mate i'll make
you up
all right peace
you